[inaudible]
sorry,
53,000 ton flagship of Admiral Halsey
becomes the scene of an unforgettable
ceremony marking the complete and primal
surrender of Japan.
On August the 15th of 1945 having
suffered the only nuclear bomb attack in
history only a few days previously for
Japanese government's finally
surrendered.
Ash Supreme Commander for the allied
powers.
I announced my firm in the tradition of
the country that I represent crocheted
and the discharge if my responsibilities
while taking all national,
sorry,
just position to ensure at the term
surrender our pull,
a pump play and faithfully complied
with.
At that moment,
Japan was the defeated country.
Its economy was shattered in the
Japanese.
It's suffered unimaginable damage.
Not only were they immersed in extreme
poverty,
they had also lost more than 3 million
compatriots,
brothers,
sons,
even mothers wore it.
Takes a terrible toll with this grim
picture is the situation in 1945 the
question that we might ask ourselves is,
well,
how did Japan managed to become one of
the greatest economic powers on the
planet in such a short amount of time?
And how did the Japanese recover so
quickly with such might.
Okay.
Dev you out here on visual politic,
we've already talked about the
differences between the German model and
the Japanese model.
We've also told you about how Japan
transformed from a Med eval country to a
thriving modern nation.
However,
we still need to answer the question of
how Japan managed to become a great
wells power interest a few years.
Let me tell you right now for the
Japanese model is rather peculiar,
so we're going to need more than one
video to explain it here in this video,
we're going to see a few brush strokes
in the whole picture that don't worry.
More chapters are absolutely going
falling.
The post war 45 it seemed like
everything that had been built after the
Meiji Restoration of 1868 I simply
evaporated.
Moreover,
as if that weren't enough for the first
time in its history,
Japan was occupied by the United States.
Yeah.
Hold on for just a second because it
wasn't all bad news.
As we'll see.
The Japanese also had three aces up
their sleeves,
three characteristics that would launch
their country into the stratosphere,
turning us into one of the richest
countries on the planet.
And that's all in spite of the many
political mistakes that both the
occupation forces and the local
authorities would make over the coming
year.
So you want to know what the three
ingredients where the main ingredients
of this Japanese success recipe?
Well,
first of all,
a huge ability and his predilection for
saving you see in Asian countries in
general in Japan,
is no exception.
Family is trying to save every penny and
much more so than almost any other place
on it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Why?
While there are many explanations for
this phenomena,
cultural preference,
trends towards less consumption in the
present,
in order to spend more in the future,
or just because of a lack of public
services,
which tend to be very limited in this
part of the world.
All of these explanations may have a bit
of truth to them,
but regardless,
these huge amounts of savings all then
invested,
which creates productive capital,
that obviously leads to higher
production and 12th level.
Yes,
savings that allow us to direct our
efforts for a long time.
Not to satisfy our immediate needs,
but to worry about satisfying or future
needs.
We produce capital goods so that they in
turn,
manufacturer the future consumer goods
we may need Juan Ramon Ryo.
Alright.
So the first days that Japan had up its
sleeve after the war was an enormous
propensity to save savings,
savings,
and just bought savings.
The second,
it had a lot to do with the Meiji
Restoration of 18
the yes,
you'll see as we saw her in a previous
video,
one of the first things the Japanese
government did after the regime change
was bet on creating a very powerful
educational system.
They established universal primary
education and promoted universities,
academies,
research centers,
et Cetera.
Thus after the second world war,
despite their situation,
the Japanese were the most well trained
workers on the entire Asian continent.
And of course this entails a huge
competitive advantage.
Sure.
So one of the first measures taken after
the war was pushing the educational
system even further.
And so what's the third card?
Well,
is the one you can probably guess.
And that's the Japanese is huge capacity
and willingness for working long hours
and in some cases they've even taken
things ranked to the extreme.
I mean,
do you know any other country in the
world and it has a word for death from
working too much Karoshi death from
working too much is a public health
problem in Japan.
The fact is that all three of these
factors,
they gave Japan a huge capacity to
recover,
grow and create a great deal of wealth.
But hold on a second because while
having seen all of this,
what exactly are the stages that Japan
goes through in order for this economic
miracle to happen?
Well,
listen up
day,
no,
the stages,
the process we're about to explore
starts with the u s is occupation of
Japan.
After the end of the war.
See,
the occupation forces had two major
priorities.
Do you demilitarize and democratize
Japan?
It's around this time,
for example,
that the new constitution establishing a
democratic system was created.
It equalized men's and women's rights
and it stripped to Japan if it's right
to wage war,
dismantling its armed forces.
In addition to the occupation forces
copied us institutions and launched
reforms that had some benefits and any
drawbacks.
One day we're going to need to talk
about how badly the military has always
managed the economy of countries they've
controls,
but that's something we'll deal with in
a future video.
The fact is that the priority of these
reforms was to eliminate,
or at least to reduce the power of the
auto.
Oxy supported Japanese expansionism and
militarism to do so.
The sale of lands from big landowners to
small farmers.
It was approved measures were taken to
dissolve these I babbsu large business
groups.
There's engaged in many activities,
but we're controlled by a single family
and antitrust law that outlawed
monopolies was also passed in 1947 and
the unionization of workers was also
promoted.
Everything was done with the intention
of achieving an economic power chain.
Of course,
some of these measures,
in addition to limiting the power of the
great oligarchs also had some rather
positive consequences.
For example,
the land of distribution managed to turn
many farmers into owners need demise of
many of these.
I've soup to the emergence of many small
and medium sized enterprises.
In spite of everything the recovery,
it was much slower than expected.
However,
in the 1950s the country has is as it
were,
a stroke of luck.
The Korean War Tan Japan into one of the
alliance forces suppliers there by
boosting their exports and that
production southern leave,
Japanese companies and politicians,
they discovered the great global market
gets
in 1953 production level says already
suppose to levels that have been right
before the war and as the minutes of
class had a new priority boosting
economic growth through business.
The economic takeoff folks,
the decades of the fifties sixties and
seventies miraculous years,
they were Japan's golden age.
It was a time led by the Liberal
Democratic Party,
a political party that ruled the country
for almost 40 uninterrupted years.
A few years ago.
By the way,
it was discovered that the CIA actually
gave a lot of money to support the
party's political campaigns.
This is also the party of the current
Prime Minister Shinzo our bay.
The fact is that this party launched a
very peculiar system.
See,
on the one hand,
it promoted policies that favored
keeping inflation under control and
slowing down the growth of the public
sector as well as maintaining low taxes
and avoiding the accumulation of debt.
This is the opposite of what they do in
countries like Argentina or obesity,
for example.
However,
hold on just a second because that's not
all.
Now,
on the other hand,
unlike what happens in other countries
that achieved great economic takeoff,
the truth is that these governments,
they were quite interventionalist,
for example,
they decided to promote certain
industries which they themselves chosen,
which they helped grow from within the
government itself.
They also promoted a new counter
lization of national companies
supposedly to avoid what they considered
to be excessive competition.
Although you know,
I don't really know her,
but that just sure sounds like a way for
them to help out their friends
regardless.
It did have amazing results.
In the early 1960s Prime Minister High
Eto Keytar announced a plan to double
the size of Japan's economy in just 10
years to reach this goal of the country
needed to maintain an annual average
growth rate of 7.2% for that entire
time.
International analysts considered it
impossible.
10 years later,
Japan had far exceeded its goal.
The country had Moza blind the size of
its economy by 2.8 because he did an
average annual growth rate of more than
9.3%
okay,
Dustin?
1973 the Japanese economy had multiplied
more than five since 1953 that is in
just 20 years on the other hand,
GDP per capita and multiplied by four
and within a few years,
Japan became the largest asset holder in
the world and the largest humanitarian
aid provider,
even the Tokyo Stock Exchange managed to
outperform the New York Stock Exchange
for a short period of time.
But you know what?
This is when a great controversy arose.
I want to cite some defended the country
spectacular growth despite all of these
government policies.
That is to say that the three things we
covered at the beginning of this video
savings work and training was so strong
that they managed to take off in spite
of the government's interference,
but some argue that since the government
caps the macro economic parameters under
control of these public policies
actually accelerated the country is
great.
Well,
now the only question is which one do
you think is right?
Which group do you belong to?
While leave your answer in the comments
section below and also in this survey,
what there's little doubt about though
is that it was exactly during that time
that some of the greatest imbalances
that lead the country into a huge crisis
from which it hasn't yet recovered
emerged,
but we already talked about that in this
previous other video.
So well,
I really hope you enjoyed this video.
Please do hit that like button if you
did,
and don't forget to subscribe for brand
new videos.
Also,
don't forget to check it.
Our friends at the reconsider media
podcast,
they provided the vocals in this episode
that we're not mine.
Also,
this channel is possible because of
Patriot and our patrons on that
platform.
Please consider joining them and
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage.
And as always,
I'll see you in the next few
term.